the c4 winter school really allowed me  to see how  different and rich the approaches could  be even to the same problem on which  i myself specialized there are so many  people from very different backgrounds  diverse backgrounds different stages of  the career and all open-minded and  willing to discuss and dialogue  now i can talk to people from different  fields about different things  and  that basically gave me a broader  perspective of what science is  for those of you that are really looking  for a unique opportunity to both build a  sense of community in research but also  strengthen interdisciplinary connections  i would encourage you to apply now